[Applause]
there are few things in the world that
seem more constant than the stars in the
night sky if you look up at the Milky
Way you will see the same thing that
people have looked at for thousands and
thousands of years but as professor
Schmidt found out the universe is a much
more dynamic place than we give it
credit for
when Albert Einstein was doing his
theory of gravity his theory of gravity
said the universe should be in motion he
didn't know if it was getting bigger or
getting smaller but his universe should
have been in motion and yet he looked
around and said well the astronomers
tell me that the universe is pretty
static now there were hints in 1916 a
guy by the name of vest o Slifer it saw
that all of the galaxies in the sky were
moving away from the Milky Way and so
that was a real funny measurement back
then and actually was indicating the
motion of the universe
but how did Slifer know that the
galaxies were moving away from us well
he saw that their light was red shifted
if an object is moving away from us it's
light appears more red if it's moving
towards us it's light appears more blue
and virtually all of the galaxies slifer
looked at were red shifted but it took
till Hubble in 1929 really to put it all
together and he went out and he measured
distances to the nearest galaxies now
Slifer knew that these galaxies were
moving away
Hubble looked at the stars in them and
what he noticed was that the faster that
the object was moving away from us the
fainter the stars were now stars become
fainter when they're further away so he
said well let's just assume all those
stars are about the same Hubble relied
on what's called a standard candle a
standard candle is an object in space
that always gives off the same amount of
light but as that light spreads out
through space it becomes less intense so
by looking at the intensity of the light
you can determine how far away the
candle is so if I walk out through this
field behind me you'll be able to tell
how far away I am by how bright the
candle light looks by seeing that the
stars were fainter he could infer that
the galaxies were further away so the
idea that they further away an object
was the fast
was moving he said that means the
universe is expanding and you could
think of it as if he put little dots on
a balloon you blow the balloon up every
dot moves away from every other dot and
the further the two dots are away the
faster they're actually moving away from
each other when you blow the balloon up
it's just like an expanding balloon the
expanding universe does the same thing I
wanted to do an experiment which I
thought I could explain to my
grandmother and measuring the ultimate
fate of the universe struck me as being
a good experiment to do that so when we
started this experiment in 1994 we
wanted to measure the ultimate fate of
the universe by measuring how fast the
universe was slowing down over time that
allowed us to see how much gravity there
was in the universe for his standard
candle professor Schmidt used type 1a
supernovae so type 1a supernovae are
explosions of white dwarf stars so a
white dwarf star is the thing that the
center of our Sun will become once it
uses all of its nuclear fuel so it turns
out that the outer parts of the Sun will
blow off in about five million years the
center of it will collapse down to
something that is about the size of the
earth and so that star is a ticking
nuclear bomb if it can be made to grow
to about 1.4 times the mass of our Sun
so our Sun will never do that it doesn't
have anyone to provide that mass but if
our Sun was born as a binary star then
when our Sun would become the white
dwarf this star could put material onto
that caused it to grow at some point the
star ignites and the whole thing in a
period of second it goes kaboom
with the power of about five billion
times what our Sun puts out when one of
these things explode they go from being
something that's very very faint over
the course of about 20 days they rise to
5 billion times the brightness of the
Sun and then they slowly fade into
oblivion we can measure how bright they
are to about 7% and that is very precise
that's better than a light bulb so we
have these light bulbs but these are
light bulbs that are you know roughly
forty three orders of magnitude brighter
than a light bulb here on earth and so
they are really really bright and we can
see them all the way across the universe
so by measuring how bright these objects
are we can measure distance like Hubble
tried to with stars but we do it much
much more accurately we were going to go
through and measure a bunch of these
exploding stars we're going to measure
how fast they were moving away from us
or their redshift as we call it and we
were going to put that together and
we're gonna do Hubble's experiment
nearby and then we're gonna do it a long
ways away and of course we're looking
into the universe's past when we look a
long ways away so we're gonna measure
how fast the universe was expanding in
the past and in the present and see how
it's changing and we're gonna see how
fast it was slowing down then therefore
way the universe and that would tell us
its ultimate fate the universe is gonna
expand forever or is it gonna slow down
enough reach a maximum size and then
collapse and go into the Gennady it
that's the big bag backwards so at the
end of 1997 Adam riess co-winner is one
of the members of the team was showing
me the results he was getting and they
were strange they were showing that the
universe was not slowing down at all it
was speeding up so of course we not have
figured that we had made a mistake as
one does
initially it wasn't too bad I figure out
that'll be an easy mistake we'll find it
and I have to say there was a context
that the other team the supernova
cosmology project had put out at paper
in 1997 saying that the universe was
slowing down and it was slowing down
pretty quickly and then when we get this
measurement saying the universe is
speeding up you're saying going
okay we'll just find the mayor doesn't a
mistake but after a while you know like
well there's no mistake going away and
then you start getting perplexed because
you're saying god we're gonna have to go
out and not only tell the world
something crazy the universe is speeding
up but that we are getting a completely
different answer than the other team is
getting something completely sensible so
I was concerned definitely concerned we
think the solution to this is that the
universe is made up of 73% of something
that causes gravity to work in Reverse
something Einstein called the
cosmological constant and what we now
call dark energy so how is the universe
going to end well it seems it's going to
go a little something like this
[Laughter]